HEREBY CALLED ORDER FOR THIRSTY
MARCH MAY TENTH. JUNE JUNE
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ARM
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING MADE
OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS AND IS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING THIS
HEARING MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL
TIMES. AND COMPLY WITH. AND
COMPLY WITH GUIDANCE ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. ATTENDEES
MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBING OF THE
WISE MPC ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY HI- HERE CUNNINGHAM
SENATE FLORA GIVE SENT HERE LEE
MAIENSCHEIN. MATHIS YOUR RAMOS
THERE RUBIO IF YOU COULD WALK
HERE WEBER. WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT
AGENDA. MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
MOVE TO ITEMS FROM CONSENT- THE
FIRST WOULD BE S. B. TWO SIXTY
TWO WHICH IS SET TO BE
REFERRED. TO PUBLIC SAFETY WE
BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE DOUBLE
REFER TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE AS WELL GIVEN ITS
IMPACT ON BAIL BOND LICENSEES.
I WOULD ALSO REQUEST TO MOVE
ITEM TEN FROM CONSENT THAT IS
THE URGENCY REQUEST FOR AB
TWELVE TWENTY THREE- WITHOUT
SPEAKING TO THE MERITS OF THE
BILL I JUST NOTE FOR THE RECORD
THAT THIS BILL DIED ON THE
FLOOR. ON HOUSE OF ORIGIN
DEADLINE AND I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPROPER PRECEDENT FOR THE
RULES COMMITTEE TO ADD AN
URGENCY CLAUSE. TO REVIVE A
BILL THAT DIED ON THE FLOOR.
AND DID NOT PASS BY THE
DEADLINE. AT US THAT WE VOTE ON
THESE ITEMS SEPARATELY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ARE MORE FUNDAMENTAL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AFTER MOVERS
FROM AT THE CENTER OF A MIS
RUBIO. THIS IS SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. JANET SENATE HI
FLORA FLORA HIGH GIPSON GIPSON
HIGHLY THE AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO RUBIO
HIVE YOU PUT WHAT YOU PUT WHILE
I WEBER. WEBER HI MOTION PASSES
MOTION PASSES- IS YOUR MOST
HONOR FOR ALL OF US BE TWO
SIXTY TWO HERTZBERG THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND ITEM
NUMBER TEN RECYCLERS REQUEST
FOR A. B. TWELVE TWENTY THREE
LIVING. HOWEVER MISTER BENNETT
SECONDED BY. MR LEE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON A SECOND PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM KNOW BENNETT BENNETT
HI FLORA FLORA NO GIPSON GIPSON
HIGHLY THE AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
NO RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO
HIVE YOU PUT WHAT YOU COULD LA
HI WEBER. EVER HIGH MOTION
PASSES THAT MOTIONS AND- THIS
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SIX OF THE-
YEAH.